hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
and I'm John Humphrey we're gonna talk
about Zombieland - otherwise known as
Zombieland double tap this film unites
said the original cast members including
the original director Ruben Fleischer
and the original writers the whole whole
team is assembled again so in this
sequel they are pretty much camped out
at the white house that takes place 10
years later because this movie came out
10 years later and I like that there's a
time jump here they're much more of a
family now Abigail breslin's character
she wants to be on her own and then she
takes off with a pacifist as they call
him in the film you know your average
Venice Beach Villa we out yeah guitar
guy and then along the way there's some
other stuff that happens that we won't
spoil but they basically have to set out
on a road trip to try to find her and
save her before watching this movie I
was definitely skeptical because of the
marketing to this film it's not only the
trailers for this for bad or anything
they marketed it so late they didn't
really seem to even market this movie
that much at all usually with those kind
of signs it reads as the studio doesn't
have faith in the film I gotta tell you
man this is some of the most fun I've
had at the theaters all year I had a
total blast watching this it feels like
a true sequel to zombie land sometimes
with these sequels especially when you
do them so late in the game the energy
doesn't quite feel there the cast isn't
quite feel there it just feels like it's
retread territory this movie brought it
all the energy all the actors brought
their a-game here that new players here
are great - Zoe Deutsch I think is her
name my first big laugh came from her
she is great in this movie the action is
cool there's some great gore in here
there's some really awesome shots that
Ruben Fleischer brought here there's the
once stand out tracking shot sequence
that is highly entertaining
action-packed funny at the same time and
that doesn't feel overly stitched
together with CGI no it doesn't and the
CGI in the movie I think you know at
times it fluctuates between being great
and being not-so-great before this kind
of movie
you don't really care because of the
kind of style or is they have some great
slow-mo moments here and there are some
big CGI moments but it never pulled me
out of the movie it always added to its
charm it's been a long time since I
watched the first ami Land movie I
personally might have had more fun
watching this one than I did the first
one I mean I really enjoyed them both
ultimately one thing I thought of during
the movie was it's nice to have a film
like this during Halloween it's like I
wish the studio seemed like they had
more faith in it but it's nice to go
into something that isn't like a major
event you're just back with your friends
and it has this stride that is so easy
to hop back into it's not necessarily
extraordinary but I did find myself
really really appreciating its charms
and the way in which they bothered to
update it because the thing about
Zombieland is there's always intended to
be a TV show more I've become aware of
that the more I can kind of see it in
the movies and so this does feel kind of
like a really cool season 2 - zombie
lion that happened so many years later
even though arguably everybody probably
would have wanted to do this sooner I
think the 10 year jump actually kind of
gives it something nice it gives it an
actual sense of time passage that you
can really get because all these actors
have come back they've all grown up a
little bit it doesn't necessarily
reinvent the wheel but it's just as
sharp as ever it doesn't feel like this
was an afterthought for anybody involved
with the actual production you know for
Rhett Reese and Paul Wernick two dudes
who like are on fire right now in terms
of gigs that they're getting they could
have easily zombied their way through
this and I don't think they did and I
really appreciate that yeah I love the
writing style with Deadpool the first
zombie land what we've seen the show
Wayne their style just really connects
with me personally they have a unique
type of meta forth like they bring that
kind of we're talking right to you at
times to this but in a way that isn't
obnoxious I don't think and that
acknowledges also for this particular
movie the landscape of other zombie
movie yeah which is nice and I feel like
Ruben Fleischer had a great time
directing this movie you could feel that
sense of fun and happy to be back here
the word for these kind of sequels that
come out so late an argument that I'm so
sick of having with people who this is
necessary no movie is necessary no
movies that
sherry I'll say though that I like that
they just kept it simple you know yeah
it's not overblown at all do you think
after ten years like what do they got
some crazy idea but no it's it's cool to
what we might have gotten eight years
ago actually if it come out then I love
what they did with Woody Harrelson's
Tallahassee because he's grown he's
mature but not so much to the point
where they had to steer clear from the
character like he's still irreverent
he's still edgy Tallahassee
I love it carry large still very much
who they are yes time we it's still a
hard-r doesn't feel like they've adapted
their style to change in case they don't
want to offend anyone in the climate we
have today and I love that but and and
what's nice about that is I think that
they're smart enough to know that if you
just put other characters in the world
with other points of view then you can
have more flavors at your disposal
because I think there is something of a
mistake in the idea that we just have to
a hundred percent align morally and
intellectually with our protagonists or
whatever like yeah Tallahassee's not the
locust guy in the world but there are
other characters around to offer those
perspectives and what I did really
appreciate about the overall tone of the
movie is that there are a lot of
different characters there are things
that are heightened obviously characters
like Madison Zoe Deutsch and Berkeley
the guy who heavy Gale Breslin runs off
with like their cartoonish and I was
partly expecting the movie to kind of
[ __ ] on those characters or slag them
off movie doesn't really ever handle
anybody quite that way like it ribs
everybody for what they're able to be
ribbed for but it doesn't ever treat
anybody with like a mean spirit which is
also something that I appreciate about
the world they've drawn here because
they easily could and the zombies are
mean and the zombies here too I flashed
to Resident Evil because there is like a
upgraded zombie plotline here as well
kind of remind me of the first game
remake but I want to spoil too much
about that if there's one thing in terms
of storytelling that I wish they did
more with or least had it have an impact
in at least in its finale there's all
this talk about the upgraded zombies and
like there's there's some great bits
that they make out of it
you know I won't spoil any of it there's
a very specific one that they set up to
be kind of you know gnarly of an extreme
advanced kind of zombie think crimson
heads from that Resident Evil remake
they're like they're setting it up
they're building now but they don't
really do anything with it
welcome pays it off ultimately because
the threat is just oh they're better and
harder to kill you know ultimately so
yeah but there's no real things in there
that truly have that impact that's not a
new challenge they could it could have
led to a cooler higher stakes finale
yeah I felt it's such a nitpick that I
didn't even react it like literally go
was there anything about this I didn't
like yeah I probably would like this
more I think Jesse Eisenberg and Emma
Stone have wonderful chemistry probably
more so this time around I think because
of how much their relationship has
evolved when they have a history you
know - yeah with now I do think Zoe
Deutsch is a scene stealer here it blows
my mind when I saw that tray that I
thought she would be the probably the
most annoying character like she just
looked like typical the writing of her
isn't great it's not bad it's just not
anything really exceptional but Zoe
Deutsch the way she portrays that
character makes her a major standout in
the film I really think that the most
laughs were consistently generated by
her and Woody Harrelson oh yeah rosario
Dawson oh she's she's awesome in the
film
you got these appearances that you see
in the trailer by Luke Wilson and Thomas
Middleditch
it's more than just some throwaway bit
when I saw the trailer I thought it
might look like a bit that was kind of a
pramana the dead or they're passing the
same group it's more than that everyone
who shows up who's new is great the only
one I didn't really care for honestly
was the pacifist character I don't think
the actor is bad I didn't find him funny
I didn't find him intriguing in any
capacity I was just he was just kind of
whatever he didn't care about him but
everyone else I thought was great
although all the new women were great
booms woke so let me let you is woke I
said women rock this is a high high
recommendation for me I'm really
impressed with how they handle this
movie I wish Sony marketed this movie a
lot more there's nothing they have to be
shy of if you like the first Army Land I
can tell enjoy this I can't imagine
you'd be so surprised if you didn't
enjoy this I'm honestly kind of
surprised by how how
yeah usually these kind of sequels
especially for comedies this late or not
good and they this is totally the
exception to that rule so um I highly
highly recommend this and I think you
just have a great time especially for
the month of October go check it out and
I hope that then 10 years we get part
three yeah all right guys well thank you
so much for being here
you see Zombieland double tap be
preferred over the first one do you
think they should close us out with the
trilogy who would you like to see join
the zombie land cast comment below you
guys can subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification bell check a
sound the Stardust app over there we do
30 second reaction reviews for any films
TV show and/or trailer we post daily
sometimes a couple of times in the same
day it's free to download free to use
you can post your own reactions as well
tag us do today before we're at the
sublights your page of the day shot to a
man named JN Valente JN is one of our
top reward to your patrons been that way
for quite a long time if there was
someone who could survive a zombie
apocalypse jan i believe it's you why
because of personal experience I've had
with you so long you'll vanish and I'll
think that you probably passed away but
good thing you captured a card on file
even while you're in the afterlife and
then you'll emerge you'll come back
you'll talk a lot to me you have that
way about you
where you think maybe maybe the
apocalypse got to him but then no you
emerged you're still alive you're
resourceful Jannes how I feel every time
I know I move around you know how to get
from place to place undetected and you
can take care of yourself and that's
what you need in the apocalypse man the
ability to spin a very rambling yarn of
you know epic proportions because if
there's anything zombies don't like what
John way do it keep going I know you
busted my flow plastic bust brilliant
stuff what's your flow you interrupt me
all the time come on man no I'm on the
spot now because JN I just I'm thinking
about